let's go to a day in the life of george
hotz what is the
perfect day productivity-wise so we're
not talking about like
hunter s thompson uh drugs yeah and uh
let's look at productivity
like what what's the day look like on
like hour by hour
is there any regularities that create
a magical george haws experience i can
remember three days in my life
and i remember these days vividly when
i've gone through kind of radical
transformations to the way i think and
what i would give i would pay a hundred
thousand dollars if i could have one of
these days tomorrow
um the days have been so impactful and
one was first discovering eliezer
yukowski
on the singularity and reading that
stuff and like
you know my mind was blown um the next
was discovering uh the hutter price and
then ai is just compression
like finally understanding aix i and
what all that was
you know i like read about it when i was
18 19 i didn't understand it and then
the fact that like lossless compression
implies intelligence
the day that i was shown that um and
then the third one is controversial
the day i found a blog called
unqualified reservations
and uh read that and i was like
wait which one is that that's uh what's
the guy's name courtesy arvin
yeah so many people tell me i'm supposed
to talk to him
yeah but he looks he sounds insane or
brilliant
but insane or both i don't know the day
i found that blog was another like this
was during like like
gamergate and kind of the run-up to the
2016 election and i'm like
wow okay the world makes sense now this
this like i had a
framework now to interpret this just
like i got the framework for ai and a
framework to interpret technological
progress like
those days when i discovered these new
frameworks were oh interesting it's just
not about
but what was special about those days
how did those days come to be
is it just you got lucky like sure i
like
well you just encounter hutter prize on
uh on hack news or something like that
um like what but you see i don't think
it's just
see i don't think it's just that like i
could have gotten lucky at any point i
think that in a way
you were ready at that moment yeah
exactly to receive the information
but is there some magic to the day today
of like
like eating breakfast and this is the
mundane things
no nothing no i drift i drift through
life
without structure i drift through life
hoping and praying that i will get
another day like those days
and there's nothing in particular you do
to uh to be a receptacle
for another for day number four
no i didn't do anything to get the other
ones so i don't think i have to really
do anything now i took a month-long trip
to new york and
i mean the ethereum thing was the
highlight of it but the rest of it was
pretty terrible
i did a two-week road trip and i got i
had to turn around i had to turn around
um i'm driving and uh
in gunnison colorado a pass through
gunnison and uh
the snow starts coming down this path up
there called monarch pass in order to
get through to denver you gotta get over
the rockies
and i had to turn my car around i
couldn't i watched
i watched a f-150 go off the road i'm
like i gotta go back and
like that day was meaningful because
like like it was real like i actually
had to turn my car around
um it's rare that anything even real
happens in my life even as
you know mundane is the fact that yeah
there was snow
i had to turn around stay in gunnison
and leave the next day something about
that moment for real
you